Gregor tell us a time in your life where
you literally did have to quit something
and so the impact of that action of that
decision on your life okay you know what
I've never thinking back I can't there's
not an indelible memory of something
that I had to quit I feel like I feel
like quitting has never been in my
vocabulary and I feel like if I've ever
quit something it's been more kind of
putting it aside for something new that
presents itself and puts me on a
different path and so I feel like I've
tried a lot of things and I've I've
failed that a lot of things but I feel
like I don't feel like I quit them I
feel like just new opportunities have
have presented themselves and you know
like when I was younger I was really
into I became really into tennis
suddenly and boy was I passionate about
tennis and I play tennis every day and I
became really good and then I picked up
a golf club my freshman year high school
never played golf before and by my
sophomore year I was number one on the
high school team and I feel like I've if
I'm really passionate about something
I'm not going to quit it you know if I
really love something I because I feel
like it's illogical to quit something if
you really love it it's completely
illogical to me why would you why would
you quit something that you really love
because you're doing it because you love
it not because you're not successful at
it yet
so everything I'm doing in my life right
now I really love and I'm not gonna put
the we were making the film is during
the sort of beginning of the Great
Recession and we have the recession as
well and a lot of people knew personally
we're moving
we've got
but some people stayed
how does that be important
a lot of Michael 17
well that was that's one of the beauties
of goodbye promises that it really is
life imitating art and we really started
the project David and I because we were
going through
wanting to quit often kind of phase and
thinking is anything ever going to work
out what is all this work gonna yield
anything
and so it's it's scary shooting that
because it was like I'm very well the
camera might have might as well have
been turned off and you might as well
have been talking to Gregor at times and
that's you know when life imitates art
and it's uncomfortable it's beautiful in
one respect but it's uncomfortable
because you know life life sucks life
sucks until we make it not suck with our
attitudes so when life imitates art at
its core it really sucks you know it's
really uncomfortable but it's it's
necessary for for growth as a human
being
you